[Aplausos]
[Música]
el día 28 de agosto del 2020 sin saber
el primer ministro que más tiempo ha
estando en el cargo y uno de los más
poderosos de todo el periodo democrático
de japón anunció que había tomado la
decisión de dimitir lo hizo apenas
cuatro días después de convertirse en el
primer ministro más longevo de la
historia moderna del japón'
[Música]
el señor ave de 65 años de edad padece
una enfermedad incurable conocida como
colitis ulcerosa una enfermedad que ya
provocó su dimisión en su primer mandato
en 2007 claro que en esta ocasión las
cosas son un poco diferentes su
situación no parece ser tan mala pero es
que la enfermedad se le ha sumado un mal
momento político un momento crítico en
el que un año de las elecciones su
popularidad por primera vez está por los
suelos
y
amigos cuando a finales del año 2012
shinzo abe llegó al poder lo hizo con
dos objetivos muy claros por un lado
llevar a cabo una revolución económica
que pusiera punto y final a la
interminable crisis nipona luego que se
conoció popularmente como el ameno mix y
por otro lado hacer frente a los
crecientes desafíos en política exterior
particularmente la aspiración del señor
ave era lograr que el país del sol
naciente pudiera competir con el
creciente peso de china en la región y
garantizar así la seguridad nacional
hablamos de dos objetivos clave dos
objetivos que no sólo eran las metas de
shinzo abe sino prácticamente la
esperanza de todo el país pues bien han
pasado casi ocho años de su llegada al
poder y teniendo en cuenta que esta era
está llegando a su fin ha llegado el
momento de hacernos algunas preguntas en
qué momento se encuentra el japón se han
logrado todas o al menos las principales
metas planteadas en 2012 por shinzo abe
pues amigos ya os adelanto que no sin
suave no pudo llevar a cabo su principal
objetivo y de hecho a su salida se
produce en un momento especialmente
tenso en lo que respecta a la seguridad
nacional atentos
por cierto un apunte importantísimo ya
tenemos casi 100.000 suscriptores en
nuestro nuevo canal mega project con
cada visual político muchísimas gracias
a todos y si aún no lo conoces te dejo
por aquí abajo el enlace en la
descripción y un momento si además nos
gustan las finanzas no os podéis perder
los vídeos de nuestros amigos de value
school el último sobre cómo invierte el
banco central de suiza tal vez el banco
más peculiar del mundo es muy
interesante os lo dejo también por aquí
abajo en la descripción
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el despertar de japón
amigos en un pasado vídeo aquí en visual
político hablamos de la mejor cara de la
economía nipona y es que lo cierto es
que la última década no ha sido
precisamente mala durante este tiempo el
país ha experimentado un cierto renacer
y de hecho su pib es real en términos
per cápita se ha incrementado
prácticamente al mismo ritmo que el de
eeuu y por encima incluso al de países
como francia o reino unido- sin embargo
un reto porque ahora la crisis de el
coronavirus lo ha cambiado todo la
situación de japón desde el punto de
vista económico que no sanitario es peor
que la de la mayoría de países
desarrollados y es que veréis la
economía japonesa al igual que ha
ocurrido con la inmensa mayor parte de
las grandes economías mundiales ha
sufrido un duro golpe fijaos el pib de
japón se contrajo un 27,8 por ciento
anualizado en el período abril-junio la
pandemia del coronavirus causó la mayor
caída económica en un trimestre desde la
segunda guerra mundial sin embargo el
problema de japón va bastante más allá
esta pandemia le ha llegado en un
momento particularmente malo incluso
antes de que las cosas se pusieran
difíciles por lakovic 19 el país ya
estaba en recesión el conflicto con
corea del sur la guerra comercial entre
estado
unidos y china- y para colmo una subida
de los impuestos al consumo a finales de
2019 pusieron a la economía nipona
contra las cuerdas y luego encima a la
crisis del coronavirus
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea el centro
japonés de investigaciones económicas
estima que en el mejor de los casos y si
las cosas van bien la economía japonesa
no recuperará el nivel del pib que tenía
en 2018 hasta al menos el año 2024 es
decir en términos de crecimiento
económico pues cinco años tirados en la
papelera y eso siempre y cuando las
cosas vayan relativamente bien en otras
palabras la crisis de el coronavirus ha
devorado todo el crecimiento económico
logrado durante los años de abel así que
digamos que esto es algo que ha dejado
cojeando una de sus principales metas
que japón logrará escapar de su
interminable crisis pero un momento a
pesar de ello lo cierto es que durante
estos años japón ha cambiado mucho de
hecho si algo ha hecho shinzo abe ha
sido precisamente abrir la puerta a que
la sociedad japonesa puede experimentar
durante los próximos tiempos una enorme
transformación veréis me explico cuando
este primer ministro llegó al poder en
2012 puso sobre la mesa un plan
económico el ameno mix un plan que tenía
tres patas principales por un lado en el
corto plazo aliviar la economía con una
política monetaria súper expansiva y más
gasto público luego por otro aprovechar
esa inercia temporal para llevar a cabo
los grandes
es imposible el crecimiento a largo
plazo y sabéis que puedes que las cosas
no fueron del todo mal
habría sido todo un campeón de los
acuerdos de libre comercio durante este
tiempo ha firmado entre otros un
importantísimo tratado de libre comercio
con la unión europea y mantuvo vivo el
ttp el tratado de libre comercio
transpacífico a pesar de la retirada de
eeuu llevada a cabo por donald trump
también ha reformado el sector agrícola
hasta su llegada el sector más cerrado y
protegido del país y sobre todo ha
impulsado enormes cambios que han hecho
crecer la población activa e incluso
mientras el país pierde población
[Música]
como ha logrado que la población activa
crezca mientras el país pierde población
pues veréis por un lado impulsando la
incorporación de la mujer al mercado
laboral con entre otras medidas
guarderías financiadas por el gobierno y
nuevas tipologías de contrato que
facilitan la conciliación de la vida
familiar con la vida profesional el
resultado amigos salta a la vista pero
ahí no queda todo también se han puesto
en marcha incentivos para que muchos
jubilados se incorporen de nuevo al
mercado laboral y sobre todo se ha
impulsado la inmigración de hecho como
ya os contamos aquí en visual político
en este aspecto durante los últimos años
japón ha empezado a romper una de sus
principales características ser un país
muy pero que muy hostil a la inmigración
algo que puede llegar a ser clave en una
sociedad tan envejecida como ésta para
que os hagáis una idea tan solo entre la
llegada de ave a finales del 2012 y el
2018 la población inmigrante en japón se
ha más que duplicado de hecho por
ejemplo 1 de cada 8 jóvenes que cumple
hoy la mayoría de edad en tokio pues no
ha nacido en el país
[Música]
y eso no es todo en abril de 2019 entró
en vigor una de las reformas más
importantes de la etapa de shinzo abe
una nueva legislación en materia de
inmigración que hace mucho más fácil el
proceso para llegar a trabajar al país y
que mejora los derechos de la población
extranjera si nos sumergimos en los
números que plantea el gobierno puede
parecernos que no son gran cosa hasta
que nos damos cuenta de que estamos en
uno de los países históricamente más
hostiles y cerrados a la inmigración en
un sentido u otro la reforma puesta en
marcha por shinzo abe es histórica
claro que de momento los resultados han
sido muy limitados en 2019 apenas
llegaron al país el 10 por ciento de los
inmigrantes que el gobierno se había
marcado como objetivo
y es que amigos japón sigue siendo un
país muy complicado para irse a trabajar
pensando un momento jornadas
interminables un salto cultural enorme y
muchos recelos cuando no un claro
rechazo hacia los trabajadores
extranjeros que llegan con una mano
delante y otra detrás seamos claros si
no tienes la cartera llena seguramente
es más cómodo en otro país y en el otro
caso si eres un profesional cualificado
es probable que las larguísimas jornadas
laborales las pocas vacaciones y su
obsesiva cultura el trabajo pues no te
resulten nada apetecibles que eso al
menos es lo que dice la teoría y también
las encuestas sobre trabajadores
extranjeros cualificados pero en
cualquier caso la cuestión ahora es que
el coronavirus ha hundido la popularidad
del gobierno y ha puesto todo este
progreso contra las cuerdas
[Aplausos]
si es verdad japón lo ha hecho mucho
mejor que la mayoría de países del mundo
con más de 125 millones de habitantes
apenas ha registrado hasta el momento de
preparar este vídeo poco más de 60 mil
casos y algo menos de mil 300 fallecidos
números que nada tienen que ver con la
pesadilla que se ha vivido y se está
viviendo en otros países del mundo como
españa estados unidos brasil méxico perú
entre otros muchos sin embargo a pesar
de ello la sensación general en el país
es que ha faltado liderazgo político y
medidas más rápidas y ágiles para
reducir aún más el impacto de esta
pandemia y eso es precisamente lo que
explica que la popularidad del gobierno
se haya hundido
pero un momento más allá de la gestión
del coronavirus lo cierto es que el
final de la etapa de ave se ve sobretodo
ensombrecido por lo que tal vez ha sido
su mayor fracaso político personal y
también en cierto modo nacional
[Música]
me estoy refiriendo a la incapacidad del
país para garantizar la seguridad
nacional respecto a corea del norte y
también china porque amigos y el gran
objetivo político de ave pasaba por
modificar el artículo 9 de la
constitución japonesa para que el país
abandonadas y su carácter pacifista y
eso pues no lo ha conseguido y de hecho
aún más a pesar de haber puesto toda la
carne en el asador durante los últimos
años la defensa de japón sigue
adoleciendo básicamente de los mismos
problemas que presentaba cuando habéis
llegó al poder atentos
[Música]
un vecindario cada vez más complicado
el noroeste de asia se está convirtiendo
en una comunidad de vecinos cada vez más
peligrosa por ejemplo te hago una
pregunta pensabas que la crisis de corea
del norte era ya agua pasada algo
superado pues estás muy pero que muy
equivocado desde mayo del 2019 en poco
más de un año el régimen de pyonyang ha
realizado 33 pruebas con misiles
incluyendo la simulación de un ataque de
saturación si esto es un ataque en el
que se lanzan un montón de misiles sobre
un mismo objetivo para así desbordar las
defensas enemigas y no sólo eso corea
del norte comenzó este mismo 2020
anunciando un enfoque de política
exterior mucho más dura incluyendo la
posibilidad de retomar las pruebas de
misiles de largo alcance y por supuesto
no se trata sólo de corea del norte
china la nueva china de siguiente y me
parece cada vez más expansionista al
tiempo que está modernizando sus fuerzas
armadas a toda velocidad
mientras que china mantiene una
confrontación abierta con japón respecto
al control de las islas senkaku diaoyu
con grupo de islas deshabitadas situadas
muy cerca de taiwán ahora además algunos
cintas y periódicos oficialistas
apoyados desde pekín también están
cuestionando la soberanía japonesa sobre
la propia isla de okinawa una isla que
tiene casi un millón y medio de
habitantes y que resulta clave para la
defensa de japón
y es que en okinawa se encuentra la base
militar más importante de eeuu en la
región y por supuesto todo esto ocurre
mientras el ejército chino tiene en
marcha un enorme programa para
modernizar sus fuerzas armadas
por ejemplo las estimaciones apuntan a
que para finales de esta década para el
año 2030 la fuerza aérea china podría
tener operativos hasta 500 cazas de
quinta generación j-20 y j 31 lo que
superaría por mucho la capacidad
proyectada de quinta generación de las
fuerzas aéreas de japón y eso a pesar de
que el país del sol naciente pues ha
cerrado la adquisición de 147 unidades
del f-35 lo que hará de la flota
japonesa la segunda mayor flota de este
tipo de avión en todo el mundo un
programa de más de 20.000 millones de
dólares pero amigos no se trata ni
muchísimo menos solo de los cazas entre
otros muchos equipos el ejército chino
también está desarrollando una nueva
generación de misiles balísticos
incluyendo misiles supersónicos una
fuerza que podría hacer añicos las
defensas actuales de japón y aún más
según declaró en 2016 el general chino
max jones ya no están incluso
desarrollando un nuevo paradero sigiloso
de largo alcance y precisamente por todo
este despliegue es por lo que shinzo abe
tuvo siempre muy claro que su principal
meta su objetivo número uno en este
segundo periodo como primer ministro
tenía que será acabar con el pacifismo
institucional de japón y alimentar a las
diezmadas fuerzas de autodefensa
y lo cierto es que se han producido
avances os hablaremos de ello largo y
tendido aquí en visual política en un
próximo vídeo bajo el gobierno de abel
las fuerzas armadas de japón han
comprado nuevos equipos e incluso han
puesto en marcha en yibutí su primera
base en el exterior pero amigos en la
práctica todo sigue básicamente igual
digamos que japón no ha logrado
desarrollar sistemas autónomos contra
los nuevos peligros su presupuesto
militar sigue siendo relativamente
pequeño casi 7 veces más pequeño que el
chino y shinzo abe no ha logrado
impulsar el cambio del artículo 9 de la
constitución para acabar con la doctrina
pacifista que desde el final de la
segunda guerra mundial rige el país
punto 1 aspirando sinceramente a una paz
internacional basada en la justicia y el
orden el pueblo japonés renuncia para
siempre a la guerra como un derecho
soberano de la nación ya la amenaza o el
uso de la fuerza como medio para
resolver disputas internacionales punto
2 para lograr el objetivo del párrafo
anterior nunca se mantendrán las fuerzas
terrestres marítimas y aéreas así como
otros potenciales de guerra no se
reconocerá el derecho de beligerancia
del estado artículo 9 de la constitución
de japón y bueno es que de hecho las
cosas no es que sigan igual sino que
potencialmente podrían estar peor
fijaos
[Música]
hasta ahora un baluarte de la defensa
japonesa ha sido su alianza con los eeuu
un país que mantiene 78 instalaciones
militares en japon instalaciones por las
cuales japón paga casi 4 mil millones de
dólares más del 8 por ciento de todo su
presupuesto militar durante décadas la
idea era que japón se encargará de la
defensa mientras que las fuerzas
norteamericanas lo harían de la acción
lo que se conoce como el modelo del
escudo y la espada japón llevaba el
escudo y eeuu la espada sin embargo la
administración de trump lo ha cambiado
todo ahora la sensación que existe en
muchos países como japón es que tienen
que empezar a preocuparse de sus propios
asuntos
y amigos no se trata solo de que la
administración trump pues haya sembrado
dudas sobre el compromiso de eeuu con el
país del sol naciente por ejemplo cuando
exigió al gobierno japonés que pagase
más dinero por mantener las tropas
estadounidenses en el terreno como si
japón no se hiciera cargo ya de casi el
90 por ciento del presupuesto o como si
esos despliegues no fuesen también
ventajosos para los propios eeuu no no
se trata sólo de eso también hay otra
cuestión
[Música]
veréis siguiendo ese modelo del escudo y
espada y respondiendo a las propias
exigencias ojos de la administración
trump hace unos 34 años japón decidió
adquirir por más de 4 mil millones de
dólares el sistema de la lockheed martin
conocido como a x absurdo un sistema que
trasladaba tierra el sistema aegis de
defensa contra misiles balísticos que
está basado en buques de guerra
la idea era complementar con
instalaciones en tierra firme las dos
capas del sistema de defensa ante
misiles balísticos que a día de hoy
tiene el país y que está compuesto por
el nivel marítimo formado por siete
destructores aegis y el sistema
terrestre de misiles patriot era la
fórmula con la que japón quería
protegerse de la amenaza norcoreana y la
potencial amenaza china
sin embargo este pasado mes de junio del
2020 por sorpresa y en la casi una de
sus últimas grandes decisiones como
primer ministro shinzo abe mandó a hacer
puñetas este programa lo canceló el 15
de junio de 2020 japón suspende la
implementación de yesa sort señalando
problemas técnicos y de coste y es que
veréis el sistema antimisiles en el que
les habían marcado eeuu simplemente
parece que no servía de gran cosa no al
menos para los intereses de japón porque
claro para los intereses de la lockheed
martin bueno eso ya distinto cuando el
gobierno dijo que japón necesitaba ahí
es en tierra ya sabíamos que la defensa
antimisiles no era efectiva en todas las
situaciones
eventualmente tomaría casi una década
desplegar y esas son mientras tanto
nuestros adversarios estarían
desarrollando armas más efectivas
destinadas a debilitar la defensa
antimisiles que higos ató profesor de la
universidad acusó q y vicepresidente del
instituto de fútbol de studies y es que
veréis en torno a los años 2016 y 2017
la validez del sistema antimisiles ya
quedó muy dañada cuando corea del norte-
simuló su primer ataque por saturación
una estrategia que aparentemente podría
superar con relativa facilidad todo este
y no sólo eso desde entonces el
desarrollo de la tecnología de misiles y
vehículos de ataques supersónicos que se
mueven a 5 veces la velocidad del sonido
y que está llevando a cabo países como
china y rusia han puesto sobre la mesa
todas las limitaciones que en pocos años
podría suponer para un país apostar por
un sistema antimisiles como el que eeuu
le ha vendido a japón y su amigos que
queréis que os diga en japon cada vez
tiene más la impresión de que al final
los políticos norteamericanos les tratan
como una especie de vaca lechera un
cajero automático para hacer de oro la
industria militar estadounidense y
parece pues que se ha cansado pero bien
el caso es que todo esto nos lleva a una
pregunta clave si japón ha suspendido el
sistema de misiles como demonios quieren
defenderse ahora
[Música]
pues es algo que el propio shinzo abe
pareció dejar muy claro el pasado 18 de
junio cuando en una conferencia de
prensa dijo lo siguiente
deberíamos renovar nuestra discusión
sobre la disuasión adecuada que
necesitamos considerando que la
tecnología de misiles de corea del norte
ha avanzado desde el momento en que
presentamos nuestros sistemas de defensa
antimisiles la pregunta es si deberíamos
permanecer dentro de nuestros límites
cuando la capacidad enemiga avanza
dramáticamente shinzo abe de su acción
esa es la palabra clave y es que veréis
durante los últimos meses el gobierno
nipón ha decidido abrir este melón el
equipar a las fuerzas armadas con la
capacidad militar suficiente como para
atacar preventivamente un enemigo si se
sienten en riesgo de ser atacados
es decir volvemos básicamente el debate
sobre el artículo 9 de la constitución
el problema el problema es que hoy por
hoy la inmensa mayor parte de la
sociedad japonesa está sencillamente en
contra en el 69% de la ciudadanía se
opone al cambio del artículo 9 de la
constitución japonesa que renuncia a la
guerra el caso amigos es que este es el
gran fracaso la gran decepción de shinzo
abe no sólo no ha logrado cambiar el
carácter pacifista del país tampoco lo
ha logrado preparar para enfrentarse a
las nuevas amenazas incluso al final de
su mandato se ha renunciado al escudo
anti-misiles es decir en el aspecto de
la seguridad nacional y a pesar de haber
sido este tema prioritario la debilidad
estructural del país es casi tan grande
como cuando ave llegó al poder en el
2012 se han producido avances y os lo
contaremos en un próximo vídeo pero en
términos estructurales la cosa no ha
mejorado mucho
amigos shinzo abe y xi jinping llegaron
al poder casi al mismo tiempo el primer
ministro japonés apenas tomó el bastón
de mando un mes después de que lo
hiciera el líder chino su misión lograr
que japón rivalizar con el creciente
poder chino y visto lo visto hay campos
donde está claro que no lo ha conseguido
en este vídeo os hemos querido contar
cómo japón ha cambiado y cómo no ha
cambiado bajo el liderazgo de shinzo abe
pero llegados a este punto turno para ti
que crees que debería de hacer japón
mantendrá el sucesor de abel la decisión
de romper con el escudo antimisiles de
eeuu déjanos tu opinión por aquí abajo
en los comentarios y ya sabes si este
vídeo te resultó interesante
no olvides darle al botón de light y
suscribirte a visar politics si aún no
lo has hecho bueno avisar política y
también a megaproyecto y aol school en
fin muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]